Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 83. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch bei meinem lupenden Jingle und zu der neuen Ausgabe, die ganz experimentell live stattfindet, ausnahmsweise mal live von einer Konferenz, der Republikar 08 hier in Berlin, die das zweite Mal stattfindet. Im Vorfeld wurde überlegt, wie man hier kreativ beitragen kann. Die Idee war, das Thema dieser Konferenz, den Untertitel, die kritische Masse aufzugreifen und darüber ein bisschen zu sinieren und zu reüssieren, um zu hinterfragen, was mit dieser doch eher doppeldeutigen Formulierung gemeint sein könnte. Und dazu begrüße ich Peter Glaser an meiner Seite. Hallo Peter. Und wir sitzen jetzt hier schön auf der Bühne. Tausend Leute schauen uns zu und wir tun einfach so, als wären die einfach gar nicht da.
Genau, also ich möchte auch die kritische Masse begrüßen, die heute zahlreich erschienen ist.
Ja, die vielleicht sogar nachher unter Garantie auch umfangreich Kritik üben wird. Ja, Peter, du bist ja nicht das erste Mal bei Chaosradio Express. Wir haben ja schon ausführlich uns über die alten Zeiten unterhalten, denen du ja aktiv beigewohnt hast. Ich will das jetzt nicht alles aufrollen, aber es ist ja bekannt, dass du so als technisch orientierter Schriftsteller den elektronischen Werdegang gut begleitet hast über die Zeit, aber natürlich auch als Schriftsteller so mit seiner eigenen Öffentlichkeit zu tun hat. Sind denn eigentlich deine Leser, hast du da auch so eine kritische Masse hinter dir, die tatsächlich Kommentare gibt zu deinem Werk und Schaffen?
Ich kenne die ja nicht. Kennst du die nicht? Nein, das Merkwürdige, wenn man schreibt, Journalisten kennen das in beschränkter Maße auch Schriftsteller, besonders, dass man in einen stillen Raum hineinspricht oder hineinschreibt, also diese Masse ist unsichtbar und ungreifbar. Ich kann immer nur von so einem Glaubensbekenntnis ausgehen, dass das, was ich von mir gebe, nicht gleich am nächsten Tag als Einwickelpapier für Totefische verwendet wird und wenn es denn so ist, dass irgendwo ein bisschen was hängen bleibt oder eine kleine Veränderung bewirkt. Deswegen bin ich ja kurioserweise für dieses Thema heute eigentlich komplett erfalsche, weil ich als Schriftsteller den allergrößten Wert auf das Individuum leg und mit der Masse, wenn wir den Begriff ernst nehmen würden, was wir nicht so ganz machen werden, eigentlich denn gar nicht handhaben können.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir ja schon bei Multi-Pilzen gelernt, dass auch die Masse auch aus Individuen besteht.
Das ist genau die Schlüsselszene, die ihr allgemein bekannt ist in das Leben des Brian, wo Brian sich ständig dagegen zu Wehr zu setzen versucht, als Heiland eingestuft zu werden. Und es dann diese eine Schlüsselszene gibt, wo morgens seine Mutter das Fenster öffnet und eine Masse an Menschen vorm Haus jubelt und schreit und ihn halt anbeten will und dann sagt seine Mutter, die schreit die Masse an, also ihr seid doch alles Individuen und die Masse schreit zurück, ja, und nur einer zwischentretet, hüpft hoch und sagt, ich nicht, ich bin gleich. Genau, ihr seid doch alle anders, sagt sie. Ihr seid doch alle anders, ihr seid doch alle Individuen. Und das ist sozusagen die Schlüsselszene zum Demokratieverständnis schlechthin.
Das heißt, man merkt schon, dass es auf jeden Fall sehr schwierig wird, wenn so eine größere Masse zusammenkommt mit ihrem Selbstverständnis. Heute haben wir es ja, meine, die Konferenz spricht ja jetzt vor allem so die, ich will jetzt nicht das eine Wort sagen, aber sagen wir mal so, eine digitale Öffentlichkeit an, die sich über die letzten Jahre entwickelt hat. Da gehören auf jeden Fall die Blogs mit dazu, aber ich würde das jetzt nicht nur so auf die Blogosphäre abdecken wollen, sondern eigentlich eher generell auf Leute, die gelernt haben, moderne Medien zu nutzen, zwecks eigener Meinungsäußerung sozusagen die Werkzeuge aufzunehmen, die sich jetzt bieten, die ja so vorher nicht da waren. Und das ist natürlich mittlerweile auf jeden Fall schon eine große Zahl. Und jetzt fragen sich natürlich alle, was ist die Zahl, die man erreichen muss, um wirklich zu einer kritischen Masse zu werden?
Na ja, die ist ohne Frage schon erreicht. Ich bin ja voll des Vergnügens, weil ich die letzten 25 Jahre beobachten konnte. Also ich hatte Teil an der einen oder anderen Subkultur musikalisch, in anderen Kulturformen und an der Computersubkultur. Also ich bin mit Computern in Berührung gekommen und mit Brüdern und Schwestern im Geiste, lang bevor ich mit dem Begriff Hacker auch in Berührung gekommen bin. Und was wirklich erstaunlich ist, ist, dass ich da eine Subkultur beobachten konnte, die in der Zwischenzeit nicht einfach nur zu Mainstream geworden ist, sondern zu einer der Leitsträumungen, die ins 21. Jahrhundert führt. Also ich will jetzt vielleicht ein historisches Beispiel erzählen, eines der Dinge, die man, wenn man so in die 80er Jahre schaut, mit dem Chaos Computer Club verbindet, ist dieser sogenannte NASA-Hack, der damals, so wie ich das erlebt habe, damit zu tun hatte, dass wir so nach und nach bemerkt haben, da gibt es große Netze. Damals waren die noch ein bisschen inkonsistent und das Internet war eher ein technischer Begriff als eine benutzbare Realität. Und wir hatten das Gefühl, das sind sehr große Strukturen, die zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil aus öffentlichen Mitteln finanziert werden, aber die Öffentlichkeit weiß gar nichts davon. Und das Zweite war, dass es damals keine ESPs oder irgendeine Stelle an die man gehen konnte und sagen könnte, ich möchte gerne einen Internetanschluss oder ich möchte mich gerne an diesem Netz beteiligen. Das ging überhaupt nicht, das habe ich mir nicht vorgesehen. Deswegen hat das, was später unter anderem als hackenbezeichnet worden ist, stattgefunden. Das heißt, das war einfach der Versuch, als Teil der Öffentlichkeit an dieser neuen Öffentlichkeit teilzunehmen, was von dieser Academic Community, in der das damals angewachsen und gepflegt worden ist, gar nicht vorgesehen war. Ich mache es kurz, diese ganze Geschichte hat dazu geführt, dass dann BK, Interpol, der amerikanische Geheimdienst, Hundefänger, alle waren sie da. Und es war allerdings alles so neu, dass es noch nicht mal verboten war. Es gab auch keine Gesetze dafür. Das war 1987, 88. 1993 ist ungefähr das Internet vom Himmel gefallen. Das heißt, da ist tatsächlich in der Öffentlichkeit darüber angefangen worden, zu diskutieren, zu sprechen, dass es da dieses große Computernetz gibt. Dezember 93 ist ein erster Artikel in der Zeitung in der New York Times. Es war die erste Publikumszeitung, in der etwas über dieses rätselhafte World Wide Web gestanden ist. Und dann hat sich von 1987 bis 1993 die Welt sozusagen einmal vom Kopf auf die Füße gestellt, weil ab da das, was uns damals sozusagen als ein Akt schwerer Kriminalität angelastet worden ist, nämlich der Versuch am Netz teilzunehmen, plötzlich zur ersten Bürgerpflicht geworden ist. Also es wurden die Blinden, die Kranken und die Lahmen auf Bahnen ins Netz getragen, nur damit dieser neue Wirtschaftsraum, von dem dann alle halluziniert haben, stattfinden kann. Also das sind dann schon so Massenphänomene explodiert, von Staaten gegangen.
Aber trotzdem war ja gerade bei den Leuten, die jetzt am Anfang, die sozusagen da in der ersten Reihe standen, also die die Netzentwicklung zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon die ganze Zeit beobachtet haben, setzt ja erstmal eine ziemliche Frustration ein, nicht? Weil auf einmal so, wieso unser Internet ist doch schon die ganze Zeit da und jetzt erst wo es bunte Bilder zum Anklicken gibt, jetzt kommen alle. Und auf einmal war das Internet nicht mehr tausende von Leuten, die weltweit in offenen Foren miteinander diskutieren, sondern von heute auf morgen kam so der Stempel, wo drauf scheint so, hast du keine Webseite, bist du nichts. So und der alte Traum, so die Radiotheorie, so jeder ist ein Sender und das Internet ist irgendwie ein großes, weites Netzwerk, was jetzt jedem den Zugang bringt. Das war ja dann lange Zeit erstmal total unerfüllt.
Ja, stimmt.
Wann siehst du da den Umbruch?
Also zum einen gibt es das, was du am Anfang beschrieben hast, dieses Phänomen. Es gibt eine Beobachtung, die ich in der Zwischenzeit auch schon öfter gemacht habe, nicht nur im Zusammenhang mit der Netzentwicklung, nämlich dass Dinge, die aus Subkulturen kommen, erstmals so eine große Nest werden, mehrmals produzieren. Solange eine Gruppe, die womit auch immer beschäftigt ist, eine bestimmte Kleinheit hat, ist die unglaublich kompakt, unglaublich integriert. Also, wo Holland, Gott habe ihn selig, der den Club gegründet hat, hat mir viel erzählt, zum Beispiel von seinen Wurzeln, von den Amateurfunkern aus den 60er, 70er Jahren. Und da scheint so ein ganz ähnlicher Geist auch geherrscht zu haben, wie ich ihn dann so, zum Beispiel im frühen Chaos Computer Club oder so in den Anfängen von Punk und neuer deutscher Welle, bei dieser ganzen Independent-Bewegung, die ganzen Independent-Layers und so weiter. Also so eine Art von Nachbarschaftshilfe und so weiter und so fort. So und dann passiert Folgendes, dann gibt es manchmal eine Entwicklung, wo dasjenige, woran man am meisten Interesse hat, das man mit Liebe und Leidenschaft sozusagen gut und interessant findet, plötzlich auch eine Menge andere Leute interessiert. Und dann gibt es so ein Phänomen, dann hört man manchmal, also jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zugespitzt, so Stimmen in Richtung, also Demokratie ist was Wunderbares, aber warum ausgerechnet hier bei uns? Das heißt, es gibt sowas wie ein Clubprinzip. Es gibt so diese Clubgemütlichkeit und es gibt so eine gewisse Exklusivität, die man sich selber erzeugt, womit man sich dann auch so ein bisschen abgrenzt. Und wenn das Ganze dann so etwas größer wird und so ein bisschen massenhafter entsteht, so dieses Gefühl, Tür zu, es zieht, also da kommt kalt rein, da sind jetzt irgendwelche Leute, die kenne ich alle gar nicht mehr, namentlich. Es ging in ganz verschiedenen Schüben, das gab es übrigens im Chaoscomputer Club auch, wobei der Club extrem leistungsfähig ist als sozialer Organismus, weil was mich am Chaoscomputer Club immer so fasziniert hat, war, dass ich noch nie und auch seither nie wieder eine so inhomogene Gruppe an Menschen gesehen, die sich einfach zusammen immer wieder mal an den Tisch setzen und reden und streiten über bestimmte Sorgen. Das war erstaunlich und das war gerade am Anfang, also heute ist es halt so, dass man immer so einen kleinen Backbone am Tisch liegen hat und alle ihren Rechner dabei haben. Bei den Club-Treffen in den 80er Jahren war es so, dass da zum Teil kein einziger Computer da war. Das heißt, der Computer war nur als ein Phänomen, als ein Faktum, als ein Katalysator anwesend und hat sozusagen diesen unglaublich intensiven Austausch gestiftet und diesen sozialen Organismus. Es gab dann im Netz Phänomene, die sozusagen mit dem, dass das Online-Sein sozusagen immer massenhafter geworden ist. Ich erinnere mich noch an die Zeit, als AOL zum ersten Mal den Internetzugang ermöglicht hat und dann Leute, die eine E-Mail-Adresse mit aol.com hinten dran hatten, stigmatisiert worden. Also war sofort klar, das sind die Doofen. Also da brauchte man gar nichts mehr sagen. Und so weiter und so fort.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt vom CCC sprichst und herausstellst, dass das jetzt sehr unterschiedliche Leute sind, dann kann man ja im Prinzip davon reden, dass dort Individuen eine Masse, eine kritische Masse gebildet haben. Würdest du das so unterschreiben? Also kritische Masse, jetzt nähern wir uns langsam auf dieser potentiellen Doppeldeutigkeit. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite haben wir halt so die kritische Masse, eine Masse, eine Bewegung, die eben versucht, stark genug zu sein, um dann in ihrer Summe eine Kritik zu äußern. Dazu musst du sich natürlich auch irgendwie einigen.
Ja, es war so, dass im Chaos Computer Club hat das funktioniert, noch mit Hilfe der klassischen Medien. Das heißt, über diese Hebelwirkung, dass da eine Chaos Computer Club persönlich nie eine Masse war, hat aber immer ein Interesse daran gehabt, diese Dinge, die wir dann eben auch kritischer Betrachtung unterzogen haben.
Wieso ist da keine Masse?
Na ja, gut, jetzt müssten wir irgendwie ins Numerische einsteigen.
Na ja, klar. Wo fängt eine Masse an? Wo beginnt eine Masse?
Also wenn man definiert eine Masse, beginnt dort, wo es unübersichtlich wird, dann ist der Chaos Computer Club schon ab drei Leuten eine Masse. Also das kann man schon definitorisch integrieren.
Und steigt die Kritikfähigkeit mit der Anzahl der Teilnehmer an dieser Masse? Oder sinkt sie?
Die Kritikfähigkeit hängt ja immer vom Individuum ab. Und es ist natürlich so, dass in so einer Umgebung wie dem Chaos Computer Club die Kritikfähigkeit sehr gefördert und gefordert wird. Weil es einfach so ist, dass da zum einen Leute sind, die wirklich Ahnung von dem haben, wovon sie reden, und zum anderen sehr klare und scharfe Geister. Und Leute, die auch mit ihrer Meinung nicht hinterm Berg halten.
Kommen wir vielleicht mal weg vom CCC jetzt als spezifische Ausprägung und Beispiel. Vielleicht hin mehr zu dieser Post-1993-Bewegung, die wir jetzt da im Internet hatten. Also das Web hat sich irgendwann durchgesetzt. Und irgendwann kam dann eben auch so dieser Punkt wieder zurück vor ein paar Jahren, wo eben die Werkzeuge da waren, wirklich selber zu senden. In schneller Folge kamen irgendwie Blogs, kam die Möglichkeit, leicht Audio zu distributieren und jetzt mittlerweile auch Video. Was hat das bewirkt? Also siehst du jetzt im Internet, in dieser digitalen Bewegung eine neue Gesellschaft heraufziehen, die tatsächlich in der Lage ist, mit einer oder vielleicht auch mehreren Stimmen so laut zu sprechen, um auf den Rest, den nicht-digitalen Teil der Gesellschaft, auch wirklich einen Einfluss auszuüben?
Schwer zu sagen. Wir befinden uns in so einem riesigen Experiment, dessen Ende noch nicht abzusehen ist, das wirklich gerade erst begonnen hat. Und wenn ich so gerade, dann meine ich die letzten drei, vier, fünf Jahre, weil es tatsächlich so war, dass im ersten Netzjahrzehnt überhaupt erstmal jeder lernen musste, wie man ein Klammerhaufen von Hand schreibt und so weiter. Und wir mussten ja alle noch mal nachsitzen und ein Zeichen im Alphabet nachlernen.
Auch der Morse Code.
Ja, obwohl der ist doch jetzt abgeschafft.
Nee, da wurde erstmal das Add eingeführt.
Ach so, stimmt.
Dann haben sie ihn abgeschafft.
Und dann gab es die Notwendigkeit, das war übrigens auch so ein, das gehört zu diesem Phänomen von Clubprinzip. Also es gab 1993, als das Netz sozusagen so in die Öffentlichkeit hinaus explodiert ist, wann ist denn Mosaik rausgekommen? Ein bisschen vorher, 92 glaube ich. Der hieß dann auch bald Netscape und vor allem Netscape, der erste visuelle Browser, war eine große narzisstische Kränkung für die ganzen altgedienten Freaks, die jahrelang Unix gelernt haben. Dieses mächtige, komplexe, schwierige Betriebssystem, wo ich immer das Gefühl hatte, dass so eine Code-Seile, beziehungsweise eine Zeile, so in der Command-Line aussah, als hätte jemand ein Gürteltier auf der Tastatur gerollt. Jedenfalls konnte man damit bis zum Mond fliegen, wenn man das alles beherrschte. Ich erinnere mich auch noch an Zeiten, in denen man E-Mails über eine sogenannte Bankfahrtadressierung weitergeleitet hat. Das heißt, man musste die genau, und zwar in korrekter Schreibweise, die vollständige Adresse jedes Rechners wissen, über den die E-Mail gesprungen ist, jeweils getrennt durch den Rufzeiten, das im Englischen BANG heißt, daher diese Bezeichnung Bankfahrtadressierung. So, diese ganzen magischen Formeln haben diese ganzen Zauberer damals beherrscht. Und dann kommt Marc Andresen und schreibt in einen Browser, mit dem kleine ältere Damen mit Hut in 15 Minuten bedienen können. Mit Maus, Klick, fertig. Ohne Ionix, ohne alles. Das ist natürlich ein Schock. Und dass diese beiden Dinge, diese Oberfläche und die Erfindung von Berners-Lee, das WWW zusammengekommen sind, das war ein großer Moment, an dem die Masse kritisch geworden ist. Und an dem das Netz, das wir schon in den 20 Jahren davor, es waren ja nicht alle in Woodstock, es waren noch ein paar in den Labors und haben das Internet entwickelt. Das ist ja relativ alt. Es ist in den 50er Jahren die technische Entwicklung begonnen. Und Anfang der 90er Jahre war es so weit, dass man nur noch so einen kleinen Schubs machen musste und plötzlich griffen so ein paar Elemente zusammen und es macht ja richtig Roms. Wenn man sich überlegt, von 93 bis heute, was ist das? 15 Jahre, das ist nichts. Und wenn man sich überlegt, was in diesen 15 Jahren passiert ist, dann muss ich schon ziemlich weit zurückgreifen, bis ich irgendwas Vergleichbares in der jüngeren Geschichte finde. Ich sehe jetzt mal von kreierischen Handlungen ab.
Ja gut, ich meine, dass der Impact vom Internet nachhaltig ist, da brauchen wir uns, glaube ich, gar nicht weit zu unterhalten, da sind wir uns auch alle einig. Aber ich frage mich natürlich jetzt wirklich, hat das jetzt auch eine neue Öffentlichkeit heraufbeschworen? Also entsteht da jetzt wirklich so etwas wie eine digitale Gesellschaft, deiner Meinung nach, oder ist das alles nur Hype und irgendwie Selbstbeweihräucherung von Leuten, die ihren Rechner nicht mehr zugeklappt bekommen?
Also diese neue Öffentlichkeit ist da und die ist ganz phänomenal und die musste auch ihre Zeit finden. Ich erinnere mich an eine Unterhaltung, die ich mal mit Wow und noch zwei Leuten aus dem Club, das muss auch Ende der 80er Jahre gewesen sein. Und da hatten wir damals eine völlig utopische, kühne Idee. Und zwar war es, das habe ich damals genannt, das Europäische Tagebuch. Also es ging damals, das war noch nicht so lange her, dass ich mein erstes Modemilk gekriegt habe. Und das war alles noch, da hat man damals die Bits in kleinen Eimerchen immer noch so neben der Leitung hergetragen. Und ich habe die Vorstellung gehabt, und zwar ich bin ja Schriftsteller und ich habe mich eigentlich jeden Abend um 20 Uhr geärgert, wenn die Tagesschau war, so still in mich hinein. Aber ich habe mich geärgert, weil im Grunde genommen die Tagesschau eine Art von Sprachgebrauch ist, die sozusagen von sich behauptet, ich bin die wirkliche Wirklichkeit. Das, was ich sage, ist sozusagen das Herz der Wirklichkeit hier, ist der Kern der Realität. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, aber hallo, Moment halt, ich bin doch auch die Wirklichkeit, ne? Und hatte das Gefühl, mit diesem Modem, das ich hatte, und mit diesen zagen Vorahnungen von Vernetzung, die wir da bekommen haben, wir haben jetzt eine Technik an der Hand, die es uns möglich machen würde, also jetzt so ein Projekt zu entwerfen. Die Vorstellung war, wir müssten Sponsoren suchen, die in verschiedenen europäischen Ländern leuten, also Modem und die Verbindungsgebühren sponsern. Das waren damals alles noch Ferngespräche, also wenn man die Sachen jetzt zwischen zwei Ländern vermitteln wollte. Und meine Vorstellung war sozusagen, denn dieser Nachrichtenagentur-Realität, die dann in der Tagesschau stattfindet, eine subjektive Realität entgegenzustellen, aber so auf Augenhöhe und zu sagen, die Leute schreiben Tagebuch und mit den Modems haben wir die Möglichkeit, das innerhalb kürzester Zeit sozusagen zusammenzulegen und so einen alternativen Blick auf die Realität zu ermöglichen. Und das, was damals komplett utopisch war, ist heute die Blogosphäre. Das heißt, es ist für mich jedes Mal eine Riesenfreude, wenn ich das sehe. Es ist eine gewaltige Öffentlichkeit, die erfüllt ist von Sprache. Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was mich als Schriftsteller sehr begeistert, weil ich der Auffassung bin, dass Sprache der Kern von Demokratie ist. Sprache ist sozusagen das Idealmodell von Demokratie. Sie gehört uns allen. Es gibt eine Open-Source-Version davon, an der jeder rumbasteln kann. Die kostet auch nichts. Es gibt auch lizenzierte Versionen, die heißen Literatur. Für die muss man dann ein bisschen was bezahlen. Jeder von uns hat seinen persönlichen Anteil an der Sprache, seinen Namen. Das sind zwei oder drei Worte, die nur ihm gehören. Und die sozusagen mit denen er persönlich in der Sprache verankert ist. Das ist ein ganz wunderbares Medium. Das sind 26 Buchstaben, mit denen man ganze Universen auffragen kann. Und wenn ich sehe, dass da in der Blogosphäre jetzt in der Zwischenzeit 70 oder 80 Millionen solcher kleinen Universen da sind, bin ich erstmal begeistert.
Ja, aber jetzt kann man ja nicht, als man eine Tagesschau hat, kann ich um 20 Uhr reinsappen und dann kommt tata, hier die Wahrheit, so. Und mit der Blogosphäre ist das halt nicht ganz so einfach, nicht? Da kann man so mit der Fernbedienung vor dem Laptop setzen und klickt und klickt.
Aber wir wissen in der Zwischenzeit dank der Blogosphäre, dass es in der Tagesschau auch nicht so ganz so einfach ist. Weil man tatsächlich in der Zwischenzeit die Möglichkeit hat, die Nachrichten, die kann man zu relativieren oder einfach sich auch noch andere Perspektiven zu verschaffen.
Aber man muss schon selber losgehen. Die Frage ist ja, man muss ja nochmal darauf zurückkommen. Was hat sich deiner Auffassung nach dort mittlerweile aggregiert, das auch wirklich als eigene Tagesschau sprechen könnte? Siehst du wirklich so eine Sammlungsbewegung, wo die vielen zu einem werden und da auch eine Gegenthese liefern?
Es wird immer komplexer und da gibt es keinen Ausweg. Die Welt ist dazu da komplex zu werden, beziehungsweise die Welt ist ohnehin das Maximum an Komplexität. Und wir versuchen halt mit unseren kleinen Gehirnchen nach und nach immer komplexere Vorgänge stattfinden zu lassen und zu begreifen. Es gibt zwei Aspekte, es gibt Komplex und Kompliziert, würde ich sagen. Wenn man so eine einfache Unterscheidung versuchen sollte, Komplex ist hochinteressant. Und wenn ich mir anschaue, mit welchen Komplexitäten wir mit Hilfe dieser kleinen Maschinen in der Zwischenzeit umgehen können, ist es wirklich erstaunlich. Man muss nur ein paar Jahre zurückschauen, und dann ist das, was jeder von uns mit einem Newsaggregator heutzutage, wenn er seinen Rechner einschaltet, vor sich hat, vor ein paar Jahren noch ein sehr teures Privileg nur von großen Zeitungsredaktionen gewesen, die irgendwelche Agenturticker abonniert hatten, die dann dort in einem speziellen Raum, solange das noch analog stattgefunden hat, ihre endlosen Nachrichtenbänder ausgespuckt haben. Jetzt hat das jeder. Das ist erst mal irgendwie, kann man sagen, ganz toll. Und dann ist es aber auch eine Herausforderung. Was sich übrigens den Mediengebrauch betreffend wirklich fundamental geändert hat, ist, dass es ganz selbstverständlich ist, dass man in der Zwischenzeit losgeht. Das, was du sagst. Also die Tagesschau kommt aus der klassischen alten Medienwelt, die selbstverständlich immer noch da ist. Ich bin kein Freund von kulturpessimistischen Modellen, die dann immer sagen, also jetzt kommt ein neues Medium und das frisst die alten Medien auf. Diese dumme Nummer gibt es seit... .bei Goethe. Und es gibt irgendwie... Das gab es mit dem, das Fernsehen frisst die Bibliotheken auf und das Kino und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist immer Unsinn. Es gibt übrigens eine Untersuchung, die ist zwar schon ein paar Jahre alt, von einem interessanten Mann, und zwar von einem Eric McLuhan. Das ist der Sohn von Marshall McLuhan, der den Begriff vom globalen Dorf erfunden hat. Und der hat sich mal angeguckt, welche Kulturtechniken der Mensch entwickelt hat in den letzten paar tausend Jahren und wie viele davon verschwunden sind und sozusagen von neuen Kulturtechniken ersetzt worden sind. Und er ist zu der erstaunlichen Erkenntnis gekommen, dass fast keine von den Kulturtechniken verschwunden sind, die die Menschen irgendwann mal entwickelt haben. Das heißt, es gibt einen großen Pool an Kulturtechniken und natürlich haben diejenigen, die jetzt neu sind, so einen gewissen Glanz oder wenn so ein Medium, so ein komplexes Medium, wie das Computer und das Netz auftauchen, die haben so einen gewissen Absolutheitsanspruch. Also ich fresse jetzt alles auf, ich bin jetzt Fernseher.
Aber manche Techniken sind schon verschwunden. Wurden durch modernere ersetzt, wie Telex, heißt jetzt Twitter.
Die ist immer noch da, du weißt noch davon.
Ach so, du meinst im Kopf?
Natürlich, als Technik. Also die werden dann vielleicht mal modernisiert und verneuert. Aber das wird jetzt nicht sozusagen mit der Gedächtnislöschpistole...
Na gut, wenn es so wäre, dann könnte ich mich ja eh nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Wir haben Traditionen und das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Also in den Traditionen werden in verschiedenen Formen diese Dinge aufgehoben.
Nochmal zurück zur Masse. Ich muss da ein bisschen drauf beharren, weil ich finde, wir haben das irgendwie noch nicht so richtig gefunden. Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, alles klar, wir haben jetzt irgendwie mit Massenmedien eine Weile gelebt und jetzt super, machen die Tür auf, auf einmal, wie bei Leben des Brian, steht das ganze Internet vor der Tür und sagt, hallo, wir sind anders, mit unterschiedlichen Auffassungen darüber, was das Selbstverständnis in dieser Masse ist. Was kann mir jetzt diese Masse, also was muss diese Masse tun, um wirklich etwas zu bewegen? Also was ist das Merkmal einer Gegenöffentlichkeit, um auch wirklich wirksam zu sein? Weil man fragt sich ja häufig auch, mein Gott, jetzt kann ich hier meine Meinung, meine subjektive Berichterstattung, die europäische Medienzeitung aus subjektiver Perspektive, die jetzt mit der Tagesschau konkurriert, da schreib ich den ganzen Tag was rein, aber am Ende liest sie sich nur gegenseitig und wird überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen. Es gibt immer wieder so kleinere Erfolge, so ja, die Blogosphäre hat jetzt mal wieder was auf Seite 1 der Bildzeitung gebracht oder sogar die Tagesschau ist jetzt gezwungen, sich darüber zu unterhalten, was Spreeblick geschrieben hat. Aber das ist ja keine nachhaltige Änderung und Beeinflussung, oder?
Was willst du, also am schnellsten kannst du was erreichen, wenn du Krieg fühlst, und die friedlichen Formen, irgendwas zu verändern, die sind dann nicht ganz so spektakulär, deswegen denke ich, man sollte nicht auch so alarmistische oder spektakuläre Erfolge, oder Erscheinungsformen setzen, sondern eher auf Zeit. Also die Blogosphäre ist in einer erstaunlich kurzen Zeit etabliert und akzeptiert worden. Die ist von den klassischen Medien, also die haben die Kröte einigermaßen geschlagen. Das passt ihnen natürlich alles nicht, das ist vollkommen klar. Weil das ist so eine Form von, eine Alternative, ich würde jetzt gar nicht sagen Konkurrenz. Das ist es eben nicht. Wenn es Konkurrenz wäre, dann wüssten sie genau, was sie machen sollen. Wenn das sozusagen jemand wäre, der genauso vorgeht und genauso agiert wie sie, versucht Geschäfte zu machen oder irgendwie ein bisschen was zu verdienen und jetzt ein journalistisches Ethos aufrechtzuerhalten oder eben im Fall der Bildzeitung nicht. Und so ist es aber nicht. Da ist einfach was Neues, mit dem die alten Medien jetzt erstmal überhaupt klarkommen müssen. Das sind ein Haufen Leute, die wollen kein Geld verdienen mit dem, was sie machen und die sind nicht mehr eingebunden in diese ganzen Selbstkontrollstrukturen von Redaktion und so weiter und so fort. Dass man seine Inhalte durch bestimmte Instanzen noch durchschleusen muss, was ja auch gewisse Vorteile hat. Also ich habe den Begriff, dass Skalierung erst im Zusammenhang mit dem Netz, mit dem Web kennengelernt wird. Das ist ja so ein Passwort gewesen Ende der 90er Jahre. Und ich musste erst einmal in diesen gedanklichen Umfeld gehen, um letzten Endes zu verstehen, dass das, was viele Leute als große Verheißung im Netz verkündet haben, nämlich die Skalierung bei einem Zeitschriftenartikel, also seit 200 Jahren der Fall ist.
Das meinst du mit Skalierung? Was skaliert das?
Skalierung heißt, also Skalierung, stell dir den Schieberegler neben dem Text vor. Skala.
Jaja, das weiß ich schon, aber was meinst du?
Und der Schieberegler würde bedeuten, du bietest eine Information, und ich sage, ich habe 30 Sekunden Zeit, gib mir die Information so, dass ich sie in 30 Sekunden zu mir nehmen kann. Ich habe 5 Sekunden Zeit, ich brauche jetzt die 5-Sekunden-Version, oder ich habe 1,5 Minuten Zeit, gib mir die 1,5-Minuten-Version. Und genau das macht ein Zeitungsartikel von vorneherein. Die 5-Sekunden-Version ist der Titel, also nur die Headline. Dann hast du die 8-Sekunden-Version, da hast du noch eine Unterzeile dazu. Dann hast du die 15-Sekunden-Version, das ist der Vorspann. Das ist immer top down, und das ist sozusagen hochgradig redundant. Und dann hast du in dem klassischen Zeitungsartikel im ersten Absatz noch mal wer, was, wann, wo. Das heißt, da hast du zum vierten Mal dasselbe, aber noch mal so zum DC-Harmonika ein bisschen ausgezogen. Und am Ende kannst du dann noch den ganzen Artikel lesen, wenn du möchtest. Aber jetzt sind wir schon wieder von der Masse weg. Ich drück mich immer, ne?
Wir haben ja auch schon mal im Vorfeld ein bisschen darüber fabuliert, was wir so thematisieren können. Da hast du den Begriff gebracht, dass es einen Übergang gibt von den Massenmedien zu den Medienmassen, weil man ja jetzt nicht nur mit vielen Individuen zu tun hat, sondern dass ja im Prinzip auch viele separate Medienkanäle entstehen. Was hat denn das für einen Einfluss auf die Massenmedien?
Also, kurzer Exkurs. Es gab einen Moment, der für mich ein Schlüsselmoment war. 1978 bin ich einem Freund begegnet, der zu mir sagte, ich habe einen Computer zu Hause. Und das war so, wie wenn jemand zu einem sagte damals, ich habe einen Anti-Schwerkraft-Generator zu Hause. Okay, will ich sehen, sofort. Dann stand da so eine hässliche, platt gefahrene Plastik-Schreibmaschine. Tandy TRS-80, falls das jemand noch was sagt, so ein digitales Drittergrammophon, Diskettensstationen gab es noch nicht. Da war eine Audiokassetten-Abspieleinrichtung drin, so mit Aussteuerungsregelung. Wenn man ein bisschen zu sehr am Tisch gereimpelt hat, dann muss man wieder von vorne anfangen. Ich habe als erstes unterm Tisch geguckt und sagte, wo ist der Computer? Weil ich dachte, da muss irgendwie so groß wie eine Waschmaschine sein. Oder so, mindestens. Nee, das ist alles da drin. Und dann stand da ein Fernseher. Es gab bestimmte Begrifflichkeiten damals. Gar nicht mit dem Begriff Computermonitor gab es überhaupt nicht. Und okay, das war auch tatsächlich an den Fernseher angeschlossen. So, und da stand der Fernseher. Und der Fernseher ist ja der Inbegriff, das war das Massenmedium. 1978 war der Fernseher das Massenmedium. So, das elektronische Massenmedium. Und ich bin ja aufgewachsen mit dem Fernseher. Alles was ich 20 Jahre lang davor mit einem Fernseher machen konnte, war ein AUS, hell, dunkel, laut, leise. Und alles andere war in diesem kathodischen Vakuum in der Bildröhre eingeschlossen und wurde von außerhalb von den großen Sendeanstalten zugeliefert. Es war vollkommen klar, dass das sozusagen so ein spirituelles Refugium ist. Also da darf man nicht ran. Als ich ein kleiner Junge war, musste ich sogar meinen Vater immer fragen, wenn ich vom ersten ins zweite Programm umschalten wollte. Und das war schon klar, dass das so eine besondere Maschine ist. So, und da stand dann dieser Computer. Und mein Freund liess als erstes so ein Basic-Programm über den Bildschirm laufen. Und ich sah Worte und ich sah Zahlen dazwischen und habe nichts verstanden. Und da fang ich dann als Schriftsteller an zu reagieren, weil wenn ich was nicht verstehe, was irgendwie mit Worten zu tun hat, dann befällt mich so das Unbezehnbare. Wir dürfen uns das so verstehen, da muss ich jetzt sofort wissen, wie das geht und wie diese Sprache geht. Das war das eine. Und dann sagt er zu mir, ich darf auch mal, weil es natürlich klar ist, wenn wir jetzt mal selber berühren, dieses mystische Objekt. Okay, und dann saß ich da und tippte Hallo. Und dann war Hallo sofort im Fernsehen. Und das hat mich umgeschmissen. Weil es war damals so, dass es gab schon Videokameras, also da muss man aber immer so einen Polarwagen mit Akkus, mit Autopartränen in der Sich her schleppen und so. Also damit hätte man sozusagen in dieses Bildröhrenvakuum auch eindringen können, aber das war so ein bisschen außer der Vorstellung. Und diese Leichtigkeit, mit der diese kleine Maschine noch dazu mein Medium, die Sprache, ins Fernsehen hinein befördert hat, da habe ich begriffen, was ein Hacker ist, ohne zu wissen, was das ist, was das bedeutet. Das heißt, da ist diese kleine Maschine, die es mir möglich gemacht hat, in diesen als vollkommen verschlossen geglaubten Raum einzudringen. So, Sprung. Der Fernseher und diese Bildröhre und diese Belieferung durch die großen Anstalten, wie das schon doppelteutig auch heißt, das ist die alte Welt, die ist immer noch da, die wird auch noch lange da sein. Und dann hat sozusagen die neue Welt stattgefunden, dass ich was schreiben kann und dass ich in den Fernseher reingehe. Und das ist das, was sich jetzt in der Zwischenzeit ganz generell geändert hat. In der Zwischenzeit wachsen Generationen auf, für die das vollkommen selbstverständlich ist, dass es zwei Arten von Massenmedien mindestens gibt, also die konsumistischen, die, dass man sich halt so ein, was ja schön ist, ich leg mich in meine Mehrlösung und schalte den Fernseher ein und also das Passivum und das Aktivum, ich geh ins Netz, ich guck, was ist im Netz zu finden oder was kann ich jetzt, in welcher Form kann ich mich äußern im Netz? Natürlich haben wir jetzt das Problem der Vielfalt und der, die vielfaltweit übersteigenden Überfülle, Verschwendung, Vergeurung, das sind, eigentlich sind das Naturprinzipien. Auf jeder Pusteblume sind mindestens hundert so kleine Fallschirme drauf, damit einer überlebt. Und wir haben das in der Zwischenzeit eben auch in unserer Kulturproduktion übernommen, dieses ganze Prinzip. Das ist fantastisch auch, weiß ich, dann so auf verschiedenen Wegen. Das Beste mag ich es mir natürlich auch das Lauteste und Greilste bemerkbar machen kann.
Das heißt, wenn die Blogosphäre eine Pusteblume ist, wenn ich jetzt mal diese Assoziation übertrage, dann geht es gar nicht so sehr darum, dass sie jetzt in seiner gemeinsamen Masse sozusagen nicht als Summe spricht, sondern es geht nur darum, dass möglichst viele sprechen, damit einer durchkommt mit seiner Stimme. Und das ist dann die eigentliche Auswirkung dieses Mediums?
Ja, das kommen ja alle durch.
Das ist so ein bisschen, das hat so etwas sperma-tuites irgendwie.
Es gibt ja, es gibt natürlich, es gibt natürlich immer wieder, also ich erzähl eine Geschichte, wie ich Schriftsteller geworden bin. Ich hab schon immer gerne Bücher gelesen. Und es gab ein paar Bücher, als ich 14, 15, 16 und im Keks war, die hab ich gelesen und nachdem ich das Buch gelesen hab und wieder hochgeguckt hab, hab ich gemerkt, die Welt hat sich verändert. Alles ist größer, der Himmel ist höher und die Welt ist mehr geworden. Und das ist irgendwo in dem Buch, ich wusste es auch noch, und hab's gespürt, an einem Absatz passiert. Und es ist ein vollkommen Rätsel, also ein fast magischer Moment. Ich hab das dann noch drei, viermal erlebt. Und das ist ein Phänomen, das wird wahrscheinlich jeder in der einen oder anderen Form kennen. Und es ist so, dass die Autoren, deren Bücher ich da gelesen hab, es sicher nicht gesagt haben oder in irgendeiner Weise haben anlegen können oder beabsichtigen können, wir möchten gerne, dass dieser Absatz das Leben von Peter Glaser verändert. Das ist aber passiert. Und genau so vielschichtig ist die Wirkungsform von dem, was in der Blogosphäre passiert. Das heißt, du hast so offensichtliche Wirkungsformen, also du hast so eine Reizreaktionsform, wenn du jetzt gegen RFID einen Protest veranstaltest, eine Demo organisierst und so weiter, dann siehst du das. Aber es gibt noch viel Wirkungsvollere. Also wenn ein Buch auf so ein bisschen Sprache, auf so eine ganz stille, leise Art und Weise, mein ganzes Leben verändern kann. Und als ich erlebt habe, ein paar Mal, dass sowas passieren kann mit Sprache, habe ich gedacht, ich möchte Schriftsteller werden, ich möchte sowas auch können. Weil das hat mich dermaßen beeindruckt, was mit mir und mit der Sprache passiert ist, dass ich mir dachte, ich will mal versuchen, ob ich das auch kann. Und ich denke mal, dass sozusagen in der Blosphäre, in den Texten, also das ist sozusagen nicht, oder nur ganz schwer, strukturierbar und definierbar, was da zu finden ist, was da für jeden von uns irgendwie schlummert an Potenzial drin. Also ich würde sagen, die Dinge, über die man als offensichtliche Wirkungen reden kann, das ist nur eine Oberfläche. Da gibt es ein viel größeres Potenzial an Dingen, die da als Inspiration, als Anregung, das gibt es auch in kleineren Formen. Also es muss jetzt nicht gleich so dramatisch sein, dass das ganze Leben von einem verändert. Das reicht ja schon, wenn man ein gutes Popstück hört. Zwei Minuten Musik hören oder drei, und ich bin dann plötzlich ganz woanders an dem schönen Ort und kann dir auch nicht genau sagen, was passiert ist. Aber es ist toll.
Du bist jetzt natürlich, ist ja klar, bist ja Schriftsteller, bist ja immer sehr am Wort. Logosphäre war das erste, aber mittlerweile haben wir es ja auch mit anderen Medien zu tun. Und da stellt sich ja dann weniger gegen die Zeitung, sondern eben gegen das, wo du damals Hallo reingeschrieben hast. Was heißt gegen? Es stellt sich erstmal genau neben das Fernsehen und das Radio. So aus meiner persönlichen Betrachtung heraus würde ich sagen, wenn ich mir anschaue, wie viel Kritisches in der schreibenden Masse zu finden ist, dass ich das nicht auch nur im Ansatz, im gleichen Maße feststellen kann, in dem was vor allem in Video, aber vielleicht auch in Audio zu finden ist. Ist das schwieriger?
Man muss jetzt dazu sagen, ich habe vorhin gesprochen von diesem großen Experiment, das wir gerade alle miteinander stattfinden lassen. Dieses Experiment, in dem zum Beispiel eine Generation aufwächst, für die es im Chrone genommen ein sonderbarer Gedanke ist, irgendwas nicht im Netz mitzuteilen. Wo ich mir dann schon wieder wie so ein konservatives Mammut vorkomme, wenn ich eine Vorstellung von Privatsphäre transportiere, die sozusagen ein bisschen restriktiver ist. Es gibt aber noch ganz andere Sachen. Es gibt zum Beispiel diese zunehmende Vielfalt an Kanälen. Es gibt Untersuchungen, ich hab mir das mal angeguckt, die über die letzten 10, 15 Jahre beobachtet haben, dass der Medienkonsum, wie das so schön heißt, der jetzt auch die aktiven Formen im Netz einschließt, dass der Medienkonsum ziemlich stark zugenommen hat, weil man hat eigentlich eine interessante, was man als eine gute, also sozusagen positiv bewerten kann, der Umgang mit den Medien. Es wird mehr gelesen, es wird mehr, es ist eine unglaubliche Konkurrenz zwischen den verschiedenen. Es gibt immer mehr Medien. Und um mit den Medien auch nur irgendwie ansatzweise klarzukommen, ist ganz klar, dass man mehr Zeit braucht. Also ich merke das an mir selber. Ich denke dann, gut, so jemand wie ich, das ist sozusagen eine professionelle Deformation, dass ich mich so viel, dass ich drei Stunden morgens irgendwie meine News abgrabe. Aber ich bin da nicht allein. Ich bin ja ohnehin der Ansicht, dass Publizistik oder Journalismus, dass die Zeiten, wo Journalismus etwas war, das von einer kleinen Berufsgruppe ausgeübt worden ist, vorbei sind und dass Journalismus heute eine Anforderung an die Allgemeinbildung ist. Das heißt, die Art und Weise, wie man umgeht mit diesen Massen an Informationen und Unterhaltung, die auf uns einfluten, machen es notwendig, ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, Kriterien zu haben, eine Urteilsfähigkeit ausbilden zu können, was ist Unsinn, was ist Spaß, was ist ironisch, was ist irgendwie, wie kann man Dinge überprüfen?
Was ist verantwortungsvoll?
Was ist Verantwortung, ja zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, wir befinden uns immer noch in der Lernphase?
Ja, Lernphase und Spiel- und Experimentierphase. Also es passieren viele Dinge, wo man bestimmt probiert und lernt. Und ich glaube, also ein Phänomen zum Beispiel, das jeder kennt, ist, dass die Einheiten immer kürzer werden. Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren noch Witze darüber gemacht und habe gesagt, also wir leiden, wir haben uns ein neuzeitliches Leiden zugezogen, eine neue Form von Ungeduld. Das heißt, die Maschinen werden immer schneller, die Verbindungen werden immer schneller und die Ungeduld wird aber auch immer schneller. Das heißt, zu Zeiten, als ich da vor der platt gefahrenen Schreibmaschine saß, hat das drei bis fünf Minuten gedauert, ein bisschen Programm geladen, hat man willenlos über sich ergehen lassen. Zwei, drei Jahre später, als man dann disketten hatte, ist man schon ein bisschen ungeduldiger geworden. Dann musste man vielleicht nur noch 30 Sekunden warten und dann merkte man, dass es nervt auch. Und dann im Netz bauten sich die Seiten lang auf. Am Anfang dauerte das manchmal, wenn ein bisschen mehr Grafik war im Web, in den frühen 90er Jahren dauerte das auch mal ein, zwei Minuten, bis irgendwie eine Seite aufgebaut war. Und so weiter und so weiter. Und dann habe ich gesagt, im Chronik genommen fehlt eine Kulturform, nämlich, was ja eigentlich lästig ist, ist, dass diese neuen Formen von Kommunikations- und Informationstechnik einem so den Lebensfordler perforieren. Das heißt, im Chronik genommen macht man eigentlich ganz gern Dinge, die so eine Kontinuität haben, die durchgehen. Man fängt gern was an und hört dann auf damit. Man wird ungern unterbrochen und so weiter. Dann ist aber dieses ganze Netz, also per se eine Struktur, die sozusagen eigentlich nur dazu da ist, dass man so von Holz hin aufs Stöckchen kommt. Und jetzt entwickelt man eben Strategien. Ich hab mir dann gedacht, naja, man müsste eigentlich, müssten die Kulturproduzenten, Musiker oder Kartonisten oder wer auch immer auf den Trichter kommen und sozusagen so kleine Pausenfüller machen, so 10 oder 30 Sekunden Kulturgut, so Minis. Also Sachen, die noch kleiner als eine Single sind, Musikstücke, die noch kürzer sind. Und siehe da, was kam als nächstes, die Klingeltöne und die ganzen Sachen. Und das Interessante ist auch, dass eine kurze Form, die ja auch ein Welterfolg geworden ist, SMS, gerade aufgekommen ist, zu der Zeit, als der Telegram-Dienst international abgeschafft worden ist. Das heißt, da ist bloß dasselbe Prinzip nochmal durch die Hintertür in diese neue Technik eins zu eins wieder übernommen worden. In der Zwischenzeit ist es so, also Twitter und, und, und, und, und wer sich im Netz ein bisschen umguckt, wird sehr, sehr viele Formen finden, Darreichungsformen. Also ich kenne zum Beispiel, es gibt eine Kartonistin aus, aus San Francisco, die macht so kleine Trickfilme mit Hasen, die macht, die hat in der Zwischenzeit 40 oder 50 große Hollywood-Filme, die sie alle noch mal nachzeichnet. Titanic und so weiter, ne, mit Kanäkel, mit Kanäkel und die sind alle genau 60 Sekunden lang. Und das ist so eine Form, ne, oder es gibt zum Beispiel jemanden, Titanic im Film oder was? Ja, ja, genau. Der ganze Film in 60 Sekunden mit Kaninchen gespielt. Und diese kurzen Formen, das Phänomen ist einfach, das gibt es in sehr vielen verschiedenen Formen. Es gibt keine Beschleunigung. Es gibt eine Zunahme an kleinteiligen Formen. YouTube ist das sozusagen. Natürlich gibt es auf YouTube auch der 1,5-Stunden-Filme. Die sind aber eher selten. Die Standardlänge ist eine Minute. Ein bis drei Minuten, vielleicht ein bisschen drüber, aber die Minute ist wirklich sehr handhabar. Twitter ist sozusagen die SMS plus Netz. Also da hat jetzt das Internet sozusagen die SMS eingeatmet. Und es ist im Grunde genommen, der kulturpessimistische Ansatz wäre, den kennen wir ja auch schon länger, also so wie das hat man bei MTV auch schon immer gehört, das sind alle so schnell, ich kann nicht mehr usw. Und das ist vollkommen ein Quatsch. Das erinnert mich übrigens auch an die Zeit, als wir noch keine Monitore hatten, sondern wirklich vorm Fernseher saßen, mit diesen niedrigen Flimmerfrequenzen, weswegen man dann einfach nach 10 Minuten rote Augen hatte, weil das alles flimmerte. Und dann war es so, dass dieses Flimmern bei den Monitoren, die dann so nach und nach angeboten worden sind, im Grunde genommen erst noch mal zugenommen hat. Das heißt, die Flimmern, weil die Bildfrequenz beschleunigt wurde, ist eine Zeit lang noch mehr. Und dann gab es diese magische Grenze von 72 Hertz, wo das menschliche Auge sich betrügen lässt und das Gefühl hat, das Bild steht. Das heißt, es gibt Phasenübergänge, wo so eine Beschleunigung eine Zeit lang eine große Unruhe erzeugt. Und dann tritt aber wieder, also sozusagen, das kann man vielleicht auch verallgemeinern, auf das, was uns mit den ganzen Medien passiert. Also momentan flimmert es ziemlich stark wieder. Und wir suchen irgendwelche Strategien und Möglichkeiten, mit dieser Vielfalt umzugehen und ein Maximum davon aufzunehmen. Und eine sehr gute Strategie ist einfach viel kürzere Teile. Ich hab immer sehr gern Fern gesehen. Und ich hatte den Fernseher meistens von früh bis spät eingeschaltet, oft ohne Ton, weil man das als Schriftsteller nicht gut gebrauchen kann, wenn einem einer ins Ohr redet. Und als dann meine Liebe zu Mainstream-Musik, die ohnehin nie so ausgeprägt war, noch stärker nachgelassen hat, hab ich auch die Musiksender, die ich früher meistens hab laufen lassen, ohne Ton laufen lassen, was nicht unbedingt ein Kompliment für Musiksender ist. Wie auch immer, ich hab den Fernseher in meinem Arbeitszimmer seit einem dreiviertel Jahr nicht mehr eingeschaltet. Das dauert mir alles zu lang. Fernsehen dauert mir zu lang. Und ich beobachte mich natürlich auch selber.
Das heißt, du zeigst jetzt schon dieselben Wesensmerkmale wie auch der zwölfjährige Teenager. Du bleibst jung.
Genau, wir solidarisieren uns, der zwölfjährige Teenager und ich. Ja, weil wir beide, er und ich, wir müssen alle herausfinden, wie können wir jetzt einen Schluck Wasser aus diesem aufgetreten Feuerschlauch nehmen. Wir sind durstig.
Ja, Peter, ich glaube, wir kommen jetzt zum Ende, denn diese Sendung ist ja live und von daher in ihrer Länge auch beschränkt. Ich denke, das haben wir genug ausgeführt, zur kritischen Masse. Die Hälfte der Fragen bleibt wie immer offen. Ich bedanke mich für die Teilnahme am Gespräch.
Neue innovative Technikradio mit Bild.
Ja, ich bin auch gespannt, was dabei herauskommt. Ja, und das war's, Ausgabe 83 von Chaosradio Express. Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören, freue mich über Feedback, entweder per E-Mail chaosradio.ccc.de oder ihr marschiert auf unserem Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Und das war's, bis bald und auf Wiedersehen bei Chaosradio Express.
Danke, tschüss.